And so look,
when someone stands up and says there's
something wrong,
the first thing you should ask is what
makes.
Why should I assume that you know what
the hell you're talking about?
That's a good question.
Well,
you investigate it and you find out
whether or not the person does know what
they're talking about and on the issue
that I'm describing to you tonight,
as far as I can tell,
I know what I'm talking about now.
People have been on my case about this
in a very serious way for quite a long
time and so far they haven't made any
inroads into my arguments and most of
the time they're too damn cowardly to
debate me.
Which is also something that's really
interesting because I've put out public
calls constantly.
It's you.
You want a debate about gender and sex.
You just bring it on because that
actually happens to be an area of
expertise for me and I know the damn
literature and if you want to come out
and make your case that all the
differences between men and women are
socially constructed,
culturally constructed or that there's
just.
Or that they're just a personal whim,
which by the way is exactly what's
written into the policies surrounding
bill c 16.
Then you come out and make that case
publicly and see how well it stands up
and I know how well it'll stand up
because that kind of thinking was
defeated in the scientific realm back in
the 19 sixties in the universities and
what that meant was that the radicals
who wanted to keep promoting precisely
that kind of view just circumvented the
entire scientific process and started to
implement their demands for their
particular viewpoint from a practical
policy,
administrative and legislative
perspective,
knowing full well that they had lost 100
percent on the empirical and the
scientific front,
and now what they do instead is
criticized the scientific endeavor
itself because it failed to produce the
results that they assumed would be the
case.
So there's plenty that's rotten in the
state of Denmark and I'm embarrassed to
state that a tremendous amount of that
stems from the universities and they're
in bad shape.
Do not send your children to the
humanities.
Right?
They're corrupt.
They will.
Thank you.
They won't learn to think because the
postmodernists don't believe in
thinking,
they won't learn logic because the
postmodernist believed that logic is one
of the tools that the oppressive
patriarchy uses to sustain its
oppressive patriarchy,
oppressive,
patriarchal nature.
They won't learn to write well.
That's because writing,
teaching people to write takes a
tremendous amount of effort and perhaps
they're not so much interested in
teaching people to formulate their own
thoughts precisely and carefully as they
are interested in producing tall like
clones to go out and do their activist
work,
which is precisely what they stayed on
their website.
So,
you know,
things are not so pretty and,
and it's very embarrassing as a member
of the academy and to come before a
group of,
of public citizens and say you've been
betrayed by your institutions,
higher learning.
It's sad,
it's sad and it's not good.
And you know,
you think,
well,
it's just the university,
it's just an ivory tower.
It's like,
think again,
man,
what happens in the university's happens
everywhere five years later.
So it's no mere ivory tower issue.
So.
Okay,
so a couple of weeks ago,
a couple of months ago I did this
lecture and Vancouver called a leftwing
case for free speech because you can
actually make a left wing case for free
speech pretty easily,
right?
It's like obviously some people have
more influence and authority than others
and just as obviously it's harder for
the people with less influence and
authority to make their case known,
so clearly they need to be able to make
their case.
So that's the left wing case for free
speech.
It's fairly straight forward.
I thought it needed to be made because
especially on the radical left,
people seem to have forgotten that free
speech was actually their most what
welcome friend and and enabled them to
do whatever good things they did manage
to do over the last hundred years.
But I made a left wing case and so that
was easy and reasonably entertaining and
you can watch that on youtube if you
want.
And so tonight,
what I thought I do as a counterpart to
that is layout what I believe might be
some tenants for a viable 21st century
conservatism and these are ideas that
I'm playing with.
So I'm going to.
I wrote down about 12 of them.
I don't know if we'll get through all of
them,
but we can.
We can start with a few and this is what
the Conservatives could be selling to
the public.
Now what seems to me to be happening
instead at the moment is as Kathleen
Wynne flames out,
not nearly fast enough in my opinion.
Yeah.
The attitude among conservatives at the
provincial party seems to be something,
well,
let's just go like go,
let's go cluster in a corner and not do
anything too stupid because maybe she'll
burn yourself out so badly that will win
the next election and we won't have to
do anything that will put us at risk.
And I'm not being cynical about that.
I can understand the utility of that
policy.
Although I think it's a bad policy and I
think it's a bad policy because there
are some things that seriously need to
be said about Kathleen Wynne in her
government,
and I can tell you one noble aim for the
provincial conservatives for the next
election would be to decimate the
provincial liberals.
Not One should be left.
What's.
What's your popularity at right now?
Under 10 percent.
If she had a shred of integrity,
she would've already resigned.
So anyways,
there is a goal for the conservatives
know liberal sitting after the 2018
election that would send a message to
the social justice warrior types.
It would also send a message to the
centrists who should actually be
occupying the positions of power in the
Liberal Party.
That if you allow yourself to be taken
over by a radical fringe,
you're going to get decimated at the
Poles.
So you know that might be an exciting
message to sell.
Young people.
Get out there and knock on some doors,
see if you can take the social justice
warriors out at the top before,
before they do more damage than already
done.
She's got another year to do plenty of
damage and you can be sure that she's
going to do plenty more damage in that
year,
so.
Okay.
What else?
Here's some things you might think about
if you're a conservative.
These things have become.
What would you say?
People are afraid to say them.
Here's the first one.
The fundamental assumptions of Western
civilization are valid.
How about that?
You know it's not.
You think it's an accident.
Oh,
here's how you find out,
okay,
which countries do people want to move
away from?
Hey,
not ours.
Which countries do?
People wanting to move two hours.
Guess what?
They work better and it's not because we
went around the world stealing
everything.
We could get our hands on it because we
got certain fundamental assumptions,
right?
Thank God for that.
After thousands and thousands of years
of trying and because of that,
we've managed to establish a set of
civilizations that are shining lights in
the world.
You know now you can be pretty damn
filthy and still be a shining light in
this world,
right?
Because if you look around the world at
the state of governance in most places,
it's like the most pathological corrupt
and vicious thugs rule,
and to stand out as an illuminated light
against that background is it so
difficult,
but nonetheless,
you know we're as good as it's gone and
unless we can come up with something
better,
we should be very careful about messing
around with that.
So why don't we start with the
assumption that we're doing something
right?
One of the things we're doing right,
for example,
is that we actually value the
individual,
right?
The individual has intrinsic value in
western societies.
Do you know how long it took people to
formulate that as an idea and how
unlikely that ideas that poor you,
you know,
useless,
powerless you with all your damn fault,
you're actually worth something.
You're worth something to the point that
the law has to respect you.
God,
we don't want to abandon that for some
half witted collectivism,
which we're doing as rapidly as possible
because one of the things that
characterizes the radical left types is
they don't give a damn about you as an
individual or about individuals at all.
You're black or you're white or you're
Latino or you're transsexual,
you're homosexual or whatever.
You're a group,
you're a member of a group,
and the only thing that matters is the
group.
Well,
I can tell you if the only thing that
matters is the group,
you bloody well don't matter very much
and then you got to ask yourself just
exactly what sort of people are trying
to set things up.
So it is that the individual doesn't
matter very much.
Well,
it's the sort of people to whom the
individual doesn't matter very much and
I might suggest that you don't elect
them and that when they attempt to take
power that you do everything you can to
stop.
No.
Okay,
so that's assumption number one,
the assumption number two,
peaceful social being is preferable,
isolation and to war in consequences
justly and rightly demand some sacrifice
of individual impulsivity.
Idiosyncrasy,
okay,
so you want to live alone in the bush,
you're going to starve to death and
beat,
and by black flies,
it's not a good solution.
Okay,
so you have to cooperate with other
people and that means you can't get to
be your whimsical self 100 percent of
the time.
It means that most of you has to be
sacrificed so that you can be
approximately like everyone else.
Now,
that's a real sacrifice,
right?
It's,
it's a sacrifice of,
of.
It might even be a sacrifice of some of
the unique qualities that everyone needs
from you.
Socialization costs,
but the advantage of it is,
well,
we get to exist.
Look,
we can all sit together in this hall and
no one has their hands around each
other's throats and we're talking about
serious things.
Okay man,
that's worth something.
And what is worth in parties?
You don't get to be whatever
spectacularly colored creature you want
to be all the time.
You have to do what you can to be normal
and predictable and it's not like normal
and predictable is the highest virtue
because it's not and and being more than
normal and being and being unique and
creative and contributing in our way is
extraordinarily important,
but the fundamental point is is that
social being requires the sacrifice of a
certain amount of individually
idiosyncrasy and that's a fundamentally
conservative claim.
It's like you should be.
You should do what everyone else does,
unless you have a really good reason to
vary.
It's a good rule.
It's like you do what people have done
throughout time.
You grow up,
you find a partner,
you establish a stable relationship,
you get a job,
you make yourself useful.
You have some children,
you do something productive and
interesting with your spare time and you
try to act like a respectable human
being.
That's what you do.
That's a conservative ethos and if
you're.
If you have something spectacular about
you that needs to be revealed to the
world,
then break some rules,
man,
go right ahead.
I'm dead serious about that,
but most of the time you don't,
and even if you happen to be a special
person and you might be 90 percent of
you still isn't special,
so most of the time you're still going
to be following the rules and the rules
aren't there to oppress.
They're there to keep us at.
They're there to keep us away from each
other's throats because human beings are
very warlike and we're very competitive
and we're very aggressive and if we are
fortunate enough to have woven together
a social fabric that basically renders
us peaceful and cooperative,
we should try disrupting that at our
great peril.
Because the general rule for human
existence,
throat the centuries has been turmoil
and war and we don't have that here.
And so thank God for that and it's worth
a bit of a sacrifice.